I love crash team racing it was one of
my favorite games growing up and it
still is to this day I remember every
level every item and every shortcut from
the original and even now I can pick it
up and still compete with some of my
best lap times if the devil himself came
up to me and said Nick I want that soul
of yours but you can keep it if you beat
me in a game of your choosing there's a
good chance I'd dig up a ps1 and pass
them a controller I still fervently
believe that with its drift and
powerslide mechanics alone
it is hands-down the best kart racer of
all time and that's before we toss in
classic characters and levels like dr.
engine and pop experiment so when I saw
an opportunity to jump in and play the
remake I had to see if he was shaping up
to my very high standards of what I
wanted to be thankfully I can say with
about 90% of surety that I have nothing
to worry about
first off presentation wise it's
incredible the three tracks I was able
to play crash Cove polar pass and dingo
Canyon look great there's so much added
detail they packed into every nook and
cranny not only on the track itself but
particularly in the background
polar bears climbing along banners a
train chugging along just above the
track I was so focused on the race that
it wasn't until I looked over at the
screen of the player next to me that I
realized just how much extra there is
going on off the main course
each character also now has their own
set of animations for jumping or
celebrating they've rerecorded many of
my favorite characters exclamation and
taunts while also adding new ones that
fit each personality cortex for example
has never seen more like a bumbling
maniacal mad scientist and he does here
not only that explosions from bombs or
missiles whisk by my ears as I sped past
competitor potions I threw ahead landed
with a satisfying splash on top of
another racer and of course hearing the
re-recorded title theme music playing
through the headphones before I put them
on brought back a potent wave of
nostalgia
[Music]
I was able to speak with the lead
developer who was there to talk a bit
about our experiences with the game when
we were younger I asked him what his
favorite track was they were looking at
speedrunners to balance any of the
characters or shortcuts and if battle
mode was coming back among other things
for the record it was hotter skyway yes
they're removing some of the shortcuts
you can access by going out of bounds
but plan on keeping everything that was
designed as intentional and yes battle
mode will return when I asked if they
were considering adding and no items
variant of races for online he said that
they're still evaluating their options
in terms of new modes he genuinely
seemed just as big of a fan of the
originals me he said that they're trying
their very best to make it control
exactly like I remember and then
ultimately they will have accomplished
their goal if our lap times and time
trial are the same as they were in the
original as for replicating that feel
for the most part I think they've
succeeded from the moment I picked up
the controller I was tapping X to charge
up my initial boost out of the gate and
immediately went into lining up my angle
to get the perfect power slide around
the corner it plays just like it used to
you start sliding you charge your turbo
and hit l1 to boost up to three times
the longer you let it charge the longer
your boost lasts however it feels like
they shorten the length of time that
boosts lasts with it particularly being
noticeable on long straight lanes
without turns on crash Cove for example
after boosting into the final stretch
used to be very easy to keep your boost
going through using the turbo pads up to
the finish line but in nitro fueled I
fell a little short of that coming out
of your drift also felt just the tiniest
bit off as well I wasn't able to narrow
down what it was until I went home that
night and played the original again I
think they adjusted your turning radius
after boosting whether it's how far you
turn or how quickly you turn I'm not
positive yet but it led to a couple
cases where I accidentally boosted off
the ledge or into a wall because my
angle was off
that said I could be wrong I hadn't
played the original in a few years so I
may have just been rusty I only played
for 45 minutes and if anything it's
still an early build so there's always
room to fine-tune everything
worst case scenario it just means that I
need to slightly adjust how I approach
those turns
nitro fueled still vastly exceeded my
expectations and I can't wait to pick it
up and feel that rush of competition
again one of the games I play better
than anyone I know
however if nitrous oxide is still a
dirty cheater after all these years I'm
going to lose it
[Music]